[Music]
thank you
hey everybody Welcome to the data
science hangout let's get things kicked
off here hope everybody's having a great
week
I'm Rachel Dempsey if I had haven't had
a chance to meet you yet and I lead our
Pro community at posit
data science hangout is our open space
to chat about data Science Leadership
and questions you're facing
just getting to hear what's going on in
data across different Industries
all over the world but we're here every
Thursday at the same time same place so
if you are in the future somewhere
watching this on YouTube you can add it
to your calendar and the details will be
in the YouTube description below
Brian I think that's actually how you
first found out about the data science
but together we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment for
everyone we love to hear from everybody
no matter your level of experience or
area of work
you can join in the conversation a few
different ways and jump in and ask
questions you can jump in by raising
your hand on Zoom
and to get to that it's in the zoom bar
below where you click on reactions
and then secondly you could put
questions in the zoom chat and feel free
to just put a little star next to it if
you want me to read it maybe you're in a
coffee shop or something and then we
also have a slider link where you can
ask questions anonymously too
and I like to add in that it is totally
okay to just listen in to if you want
you don't have to jump in the
conversation
um but I am so excited to have Brian
joining us here today and before
before introducing Brian I forgot Libby
that I was gonna have you do a little 30
second Pitch to share something with
with everybody here too so let me do
that first and then I'll jump over to
introducing Brian
awesome thank you so much this is a
pitch on behalf of Andis and I if you
've been here no dandis if you've been
here over the past few weeks you you
probably know Andis um Annis and I are
going to be doing a reread book club of
islr we're gonna do the second edition
because we've gone through the first
edition and segmentation came out I
think like August of last year or
something and
um it has fantastic resources because
everything is
really really made available by the
authors online there's there's YouTube
lectures there's slides there's all
kinds of stuff
um so who is this for if you would like
to join us we're probably going to do it
on Discord it's probably going to be one
chapter a month and
it would be best for people who are
rereading like we are like a lot of
people went through islr in their past
they're already pretty familiar with all
of these statistical Concepts and they
would like to dive into the second
edition and kind of experience
islrs take on some of the new material
like deep learning that's been added so
if you are interested in that please
private DM Andis or I uh your email
address just so that when we are ready
to do our thing together we can include
you too
or find me on LinkedIn and send me your
email address that way it also works
thank you Rachel yeah absolutely and
islr that's introduction to statistical
learning introduction to statistical
learning in R yes okay sorry other
acronyms no no worries it's awesome that
sounds great yeah feel free to put that
into the chat of course to let people
know who are joining in later too
um but with that Brian thank you so much
for joining us uh today so Brian is our
Brian Fannin is our featured leader for
the day and he is currently a research
actuary at the casualty Actuarial
society and speaking of books Brian is
also author of the book R for actuaries
and data scientists with applications to
insurance so really excited to ask you
about that today too Brian but uh to get
us started here it'd be great to have
you introduce yourself and maybe share a
little bit about your role now and and
thing you like to do outside of work too
okay so I'm an actuary and have been
doing that for we're almost at the point
where I can say 30 years I'm rounding up
slightly to get to 30 years but I've
been doing that for a while
um one of the first questions that I get
when I tell people that I'm an actuary
is what exactly is an actuary
um I'll keep it very very simple for for
folks though I'm happy to go into tell
if folks are interested
um
an actuary is an applied statistician
particularly focused on Financial Risk
the easier way to think of that perhaps
is we work a lot in insurance we figure
out what people need to pay for uh
transferring the risk of financial loss
to damage to their car to their home or
to uh to what have you uh any number of
things so that's uh what an actuary does
uh I've been with the casualty Actuarial
Society for about five years more than
five years and we are very engaged in
professional education credentialing
actuaries but also Actuarial research uh
so that's where I nerd it up with trying
to develop new Concepts to improve uh
the way that actuaries can carry out
their work
um I also do a lot of speaking as I
mentioned I was just in Boston recently
at a conference uh so I do dabble
somewhat in professional education
um outside of work it will be the same
set of
non-professional hobbies that I think
everyone does that are fascinating and
enriching to me I spend time with my
wife and my kids I cook I watch movies
uh I can't think of anything that would
really distinguish me uh all that much
outside of work I like to travel but you
know we all do yeah it's a really
Dreadful dating profile but happy to
talk about movies or traveling
well thank you so much for joining us
Brian and I just shared the link to the
book in the chat if anybody wants to
check it out
um but Brian something I thought might
be interesting to kick off the
conversation with is I know you
mentioned that
a majority of actuaries are still doing
uh the Lion's Share of their work and
spreadsheets specifically Excel
but I was just wondering how you've seen
that start to change or how you think
that might be changing in the future
so it is changing albeit slowly
um and I can say that my experience
professionally as an actuary for oh like
the first 20 years that I was doing this
was largely spreadsheet based that
that's very very common there's a very
easy on-ramp for people to work with
Excel which I think helps explain some
of its ubiquity and I'll say Excel
that's usually what I mean the
spreadsheet more generally
um but typically it's going to be Excel
um two years ago the cas
um issued a technology survey about what
tools actuaries were using because we're
curious to see how quickly it's moving
uh what we found was 98 of respondents
and we got about a thousand some odd
respondents so pretty decent sample size
said they use 98 I think uh use Excel on
pretty much a daily basis uh whereas r
or python the numbers were on a daily
basis certainly comfortably less than
one out of three I would be one of the
ones who uses R every day
um we redid the survey last year and the
numbers moved a little bit that survey
will launch again uh this summer and
curious to see if that slow and steady
Pace uh it is continuing but anecdotally
I can say that when I'm at conferences
and
um talking about some of the work I do
talk to folks about what what tools
they're using I hear it more
I think python is moving a little bit
quicker largely because or had some
penetration uh but I do get the sense
that uh there is a subtle shift a lot of
it is going to be demographic within the
Actuarial Community I'll be one of the
older our users they tend to be a little
bit younger than I am so uh that shift
is partially a generational change
and with that have you had experience
and
helping bring people on board I'm
curious what's been most helpful for
people just getting started I'm not sure
what hazard hasn't been helpful uh for
other people I can tell you my Approach
has been to zealously evangelize uh
using scripting tools I'll say R
specifically it's the one that I came to
First and the one that I love the most
but uh Python's good too
um I I have less to say about the things
like Julia or JavaScript
JavaScript might not be a great example
but Julie would be a good one they're
not bad I'm just not as familiar with
them and I think they don't have quite
the um the network effect but
um evangelizing scripting tools is one
of the things that I do that's one of
the reasons why I wrote the book so that
there would be an entry point for uh for
folks to uh to get familiar with the
language
um later today I'll be co-instructing a
virtual workshop for actuaries using R
and uh I also assist with the other
python instruction I I hope that's
helpful
I I can tell you what has been helpful
for me is just uh recognizing the
benefit that I get from uh from using
Technologies like R like python uh it
has made me uh better statistician
I I suddenly found that when I was able
to script A lot of these models I
understood the statistics a lot better
than I thought I did when I was trying
to translate pen and paper into uh into
a spreadsheet
thank you so I get to ask all the
questions in the beginning as we wait
for them to come in from everybody but
something I find really interesting is
learning about
people's professional Journeys and what
takes you to different companies and
gets you to where you are
um and I know you've worked across many
different insurance companies like
Munich re or swiss reinsurance you were
Chief actuary as well and I'd love to
hear
about that journey and maybe also what
that transition has been like going into
this um
the casualty Actuarial site Society more
of a professional Society rather than
large organization
okay um well I did say that I want to
travel and ways that I tried to put that
uh into action was I was working in
Chicago this would have been about 20
years ago now
and
um one of the professional realities of
White Collar work that some of us have
experienced unfortunately is a company
where I was working uh was sold to
someone else and so I thought well I'd
like to work somewhere
uh uh somewhere outside of the United
States so I had this opportunity where I
found myself open to other other
positions and uh was able to move to
Germany
uh not because of I had said that's
going to be the place I I phoned a
Headhunter and uh said I'd like to move
somewhere on Earth where English is not
the native language
within this particular field that means
if you want to be a non-native or rather
English is not the native language that
will be either Switzerland or Germany
maybe France uh maybe a few other
countries but that was where I wound up
it was terrific I learned German uh got
to travel quite a bit and got to see a
very different perspective
um I I know that I'm I'm pretty sure
that I'm the only actuary on this call
although if you're not please say hello
um so for people who are not familiar
with the field the perspective and the
mode of practice is different all over
the world actuaries in London are
different than actuaries in New York are
different than actuaries in Asia or
different than actuaries in Switzerland
so getting that perspective was uh
really eye-opening
also kind of fed into my interest in R
because the um
a lot of the folks that I've worked with
in Europe their statistical skills were
loads better than mine
they were able to think in equations and
be able to do things in ways that I
struggled to keep up with so that fed
into uh my chafing against the
constraints of the spreadsheet and um
I'm gonna send my own intellect I'll go
ahead and just out myself with that like
I say I know I know more mathematical
statistics than the average person on
the street but I don't know as much as
the typical actuary in say Switzerland
so uh that was one of the draws to
getting me to uh to R
um I hope that that's interesting as a
journey oh that
I love that that you just said I want to
go try living somewhere else and learn
another language and you made it happen
um I see a few questions coming in in
the chat and Danielle I know this was
also a question to the group too but I
was wondering if you want to jump in and
and ask that here
sure yeah
um my company is finally looking into a
proper database to help store our data
um and I that is not my area of
expertise at all but I thought someone
here might have
um some advice when I look into
different kinds of databases seems like
R in our studio is like pretty set up to
work with SQL like relational databases
um but I don't know what tools are out
there for if we wanted to go with a no
SQL database
if anyone has advice I would love to
hear it
I don't want to preempt anyone else uh
responding um your questions about nosql
the experience with working with the
relational databases has been pretty
smooth uh I have just for fun dabbled in
mongodb and neo4j there are libraries
out there
um
at scale there may be some pain points
but I can say that in terms of
prototyping uh and just getting started
there are packages that support uh
certainly neo4j and mongodb
great thank you
any other thoughts
or people where they with experience
with that
I see there's a follow-up question which
nosql database are using is it mongodb
no no no no SQL databases yeah we don't
have anything selected so if anyone has
suggested suggestions on which one we
should go with too this is still very
preliminary exploration of which kind of
database we want to use but um Brian you
said mongodb as well
well it would depend on on what your use
case is
um I I dabbled the nosql largely uh is
it just for some nerd fun
um relational databases are a very
proven reliable scalable technology
um they're they're definitely use cases
for others and I think would be
when I when I say I mean like like
Jason generally
uh
depending on what data you're you're
looking to to analyze if it's like
highly transactional over the web then
probably something like may be
attractive
but um yeah relational is really good
it's
[Music]
all right I was sorting through
questions and couldn't find the new one
for a second
um but I I see there was an anonymous
question asked on slido which was what
mathematical and statistical methods do
you use are there packages for this
specifically
into this being Actuarial science or are
we still on databases I think we're
we're going back to Actuarial science
yeah
uh there are a few
um
and I'll have to reference uh some
specific Actuarial techniques there is a
technique called loss reserving
effectively it's establishing the amount
of liability Financial liability and and
I'll get back to boarding stuff in a
minute but uh potential liability for an
insurance company
um practically statistically it is very
similar to longitudinal data analysis
not quite the same but very very similar
that is one area where there are at
least two packages both of them are
called chain ladder one of them isn't R
and then there was a port uh to python
those are a couple there's a package
called actuar
a-c-t-u-a-r which is I think uh French
for actuary developed in France uh this
is some support for statistical
distributions beyond what you get in the
uh the stats package
uh actuaries often need to rely on
probability distributions that are that
have thick Tails all right so we've got
highly skewed uh distributions this is a
good thing if you're a consumer it means
that really terrible things are rare
like really terrible events are rare but
as actuaries we need to be able to come
up with an estimate there so octoir is
another package
um I'm searching my memory
that maybe about it
the
which kind of begs the question is that
all that we need the answer there is no
actuaries uh use pretty standard
techniques like generalized linear
models for a lot of the work that we do
I was just asking in the chat if anybody
was looking those up and wants to share
the links to those packages in the chat
that would be awesome too
I see um Adam you had a question in the
chat and I'm actually just making the
connection now that Brian had previously
worked at the Hartford as well
um Adam do you want to jump in and
introduce yourself
yeah hi I'm Adam I'm uh I'm a director
of data science at the Hartford yourself
yeah
um I just joined uh two months ago but
it just came up this morning in fact
that it's it's very common with the rise
of data science that we often have lots
of uh sort of like resources and cheat
sheets and ways for folks to kind of
understand what data science is as it
comes into their business but we don't
often see it go the other way so
um
yeah I've been in the insurance industry
a few years but I know a lot of new
hires especially in data science uh
struggle with learning those Actuarial
Concepts and the jargon and you know
what things mean
um and I'm and I'm kind of like looking
for are there resources other ways for
us to go out and find besides y'all of
course your book uh other resources
where we can go out and understand these
Concepts and use that to to collaborate
with our product partners for example
it's going to be really upset that I
don't have one of those at the ready
um uh that that feels like something
that someone has put together
um
oh gosh um I'm blanking on the name of
the organ or the Actuarial Foundation
may have some kind of actuary and
one-on-one type of material
um
but I
oh gosh is there a way for me to like
put something not in the chat but after
this like a comment okay cool yeah you
can send it to me and I can put it with
the recording too okay yeah I'll have to
do that I'm sure that that material
exists I've not needed it for a very
long time
um generally if I'm talking to folks
even if they're not actuaries it's it's
largely more about insurance terms like
if I say well here's a good example like
the abbreviation ibnr
actuaries know what that means so do a
lot of people in the insurance industry
that actuaries uh work with and to end
the suspense um ibnr cancer incurred but
not reported that is an amount of
insurance claims that the company must
estimate as being owed to policyholders
but it's it's so standard on uh
Insurance financial statements that even
outside the profession folks tend to
know it if you're a data scientist and
let's say last week you were working for
uh I don't know uh Best Buy or Home
Depot and today you're working at the
Hartford you're not going to know what
that is exactly
like you're not going to know what that
is uh so that kind of material is out
there but I'd have to I'd have to look
it up uh uh to to share it well you can
definitely add links after but I see
Darren had shared one in the chat which
I think
is related to this Darren if you want to
jump in
yeah so the institutes
um which uh I guess organizes you know
designations that actuaries tend to take
so like cpcu is a very common very big
one but
um they have a few other uh very
specific designations that are you know
low effort in terms of the amount of
work involved that I think are quite
useful so one of them in the chat is
associate in Insurance data analytics
um so that you could take it takes maybe
like nine months to complete fully but
it's an official designation that I
think has been useful for our team also
being an insurance industry in terms of
just getting up to speed on basic
knowledge terms that can be very
confusing to someone starting off
yeah the Institute is a very good
resource
awesome yeah thank you so much you know
I I sit in these meetings with our
product partners and they're so smart
and they have this whole like dictionary
in their heads and so they're rattling
things off and I got a lot I get lost so
this is this is very helpful thank you
hang in there
hey thank you
um okay I see an earlier question you
had asked Bill I'm not sure if you're on
if you're able to unmute do you want me
to read it
the question was
um Brian are your colleagues and peers
working on local laptops or perhaps on
an on-prem larger system and the
follow-up question is would you your
typical actuary need to install and
manage our studio or anaconda on their
own machine
um what does the setup look like for
them
typically is going to be well they'll
describe my setup which is probably
typical these days 2021 or 23 to us 23.
um I have a laptop I work remotely
um so I got a laptop which will uh
refresh to uh to some your corporation
server uh we're in office sorry
Microsoft shop which means that we've
got OneDrive and so everything is is
cloud synced
um
and I think that's fairly typical
um I have are installed uh I'm not using
our studio server well although uh
Rachel everybody ought to uh it's a
really good product I have used it I
know the Hartford does I did some
Consulting for the Hartford and they had
it and it was a fantastic experience
um the installation of our indoor studio
is pretty straightforward it used to be
a lot more painful
um but but I I find that it's pretty
smooth these days
um so installing locally uh
my use of our professionally has been
largely on my own the collaboration has
usually been between me and someone at
another company uh and their GitHub will
be the way that we're collaborating
ideally that's my favorite way to
collaborate or we'll get lazy and use
something like SharePoint or just email
forgive me uh but those are those are
easy ways to uh collaborate
um did I hit all of that
um Anaconda
um
not actually a big fan of anaconda it's
really opinionated and I find that
whenever I install it I'll wind up with
somehow three or four different flavors
of python on my device I'm probably
doing something wrong it's probably my
fault uh but as you just installed
python uh and as with r it's usually
pretty straightforward if I were working
with a team of actuaries for an
insurance company that's not my
situation right now I'm one of only a
few actuaries but if I were working with
a team or managing a team I would do
something like our studio server
um just make sure that you know
I don't want to sound like a show for
posit although I would love to
um I know that Microsoft and others have
similar cloud-based solutions that would
would probably work very very well
thank you okay another anonymous
question was when you say that actuary
statistical analysis are similar to
longitudinal analysis does that include
survival analysis sometimes
uh yes well so there are
globally two different flavors of
actuary
uh there's a life insurance actuary and
then there's every other actuary uh and
in the U.S it's sort of life and health
insurance
um outside of the US there's uh public
health insurance schemes and so
actuaries are just not there's not a
demand for it uh but a life insurance
actually would absolutely use uh
survival analysis uh I think a lot of
techniques that are that are in survival
I'm not a life insurance actuary so I'm
talking out of school a little bit but I
think there are a lot of techniques in
survival analysis that have their origin
in uh human mortality studies
so yeah survival analysis is uh uh is a
thing actually I wrote a paper about
using survival analysis in loss
reserving so you could kind of think of
that as a hybrid survival analysis and
longitudinal uh analysis
I didn't Google that paper fast enough
time there
um
there are better sources out there
so okay maybe taking a step back from
some of the insurance topics I know you
said that you do a lot of public
speaking and that's something that has
come up as a question before here in the
hangout do you have any tips for us who
are trying to get better at public
speaking
um
I I think
finding a friendly room is not a bad
place to start
um so locally here in Research Triangle
North Carolina there are not very many
actuaries but I think folks realize that
this is a really good spot to be if
you're into data science or statistics
we've got the Research Triangle Park
we've got the universities and we've got
SAS here so there is a very active and
super friendly community of data
scientists uh I'm uh very much involved
with a meetup group of Research Triangle
analysts
and we have monthly meetings people can
can get talks there really friendly room
uh that's not a bad place to start
um what else could I say uh it presents
your present to your family present to
your friends that's another way to find
a friendly room uh and then finally just
just keep doing it the first time that I
ever spoke in an Actuarial conference
um I mean I I was so nervous I mean I
thought that I was going to have a heart
I I I I I I couldn't
couldn't believe just just how petrified
I was uh but that was what was that that
was like 13 14 years ago it gets easier
I love that tip of just reaching out to
different meetups groups and and
speaking there too and I wanted to call
out that Abigail just put in the chat
because we were well we were talking a
little bit earlier about this on on
LinkedIn
um but she was looking for lightning
talks for a DC Meetup so if anybody else
organizes meetups and
have links you want to share in the chat
that would be great too
yeah pretty much any major area is going
to have them I've not managed to get to
any of the DC meetups but DC area is
kind of where home office is so when I'm
going to the cas office uh it's in DC
and I keep trying to catch up with the
DC folks but if you're in Boston Chicago
Philadelphia there's going to be a data
nerd Meetup in in your town
I can vouch for Boston that's that's our
group
um I see Bill you had another question
in the chat I'll read it here but Bill
said I'm always interested in security
and Regulatory issues do you anonymize
or make up fake data if so what packages
or methods do you use
um
in the insurance space there is a need
for publicly available data sets for
research as you can guess there are a
lot of privacy issues that would make
people uh uncomfortable companies
certainly and policyholders very
uncomfortable sharing that data there
are a few kind of toy data sets out
there
um but we do simulate data for research
purposes from time to time when I'm
researching
um well two things
one again for that uh
Reserve data the longitudinal ish data
there are several packages that will do
that there are about four or five if
you're not an actuary you've never heard
of these things but that will simulate
these these kinds of financial
transactions
beyond that
fairly straightforward the uh ability to
randomly generate a number in R it's one
of those to just really Bedrock things
that I I really enjoyed when I first
started using R in Excel I can remember
I wanted to simulate something from a
poisson distribution
um at that time probably still today
there's no easy way to simulate A Plus
on which is a very very common thing in
Actuarial applications so you couldn't
do it so like I'm reading numerical
recipes and all these other crazy things
to do you know I think maybe I could
have just inverted uh the um
the cumulative function but whatever in
our I don't even need to do any of that
it's just R plus and I've got 10 000
observations so things like that and and
you can stack them so if you've got like
a cascading process where you know a
sort of a hierarchical simulation pretty
straightforward to do in our uh my
favorite way to tackle that is on the
very data frame-centric programmer so
I've got a data frame where I've got
maybe a thousand scenarios that have
different parameters and then just go
row by Road using curve or something
like that of each row in a data frame
becomes a new data frame that is
simulating a scenario and I can just uh
easily nest and unnest and summarize all
of that stuff so it's yeah it's that
Lego based approach to uh to simulation
great thank you uh maybe this is a
question for everybody on the call here
too if you want to share links in the
chat but garage do you want to jump in
here
but the question was are there public
publicly available data sets for
Casualty Insurance
oh I could have name checked a few there
there's the insurance data package in
our
okay yeah and there's another one that's
not on cran because it's pretty massive
um
I'll dig up a link to that yeah you can
send it send it to me yeah
I'll try and make make notes of where
where to follow up
um Javier I see you had a question in
the chat too you want to jump in here
next
thanks Rachel
um
yeah thanks Brian I'm really enjoying
your discussion here I work with a ton
of actuaries I'm not an actuary myself
but I work at a healthcare insurance
company so
um I'm in our data science center of
excellence and a lot of our stakeholders
are actuary
um or you know Finance adjacent folks
um we've had a lot of interest recently
trying to get
what feels kind of like a small army of
power bi devs to tap into more like
Python and r related
capabilities to
you know work in conjunction with power
bi and
like I have a ton of excel experience
I've got zero functional power bi
experience so
um outside of like
you know clicking around the power bi
system like I know very little about it
I didn't know if you had any experience
um
either pushing data or tables directly
from an rstudio IDE to Cloud power bi or
maybe using connect to facilitate that
transfer
um I'm still very much in like
exploratory mode but I didn't know if
you had any suggestions there
I'm going to have to defer to the rest
of the uh the folks my experience with
power bi and Tableau those two platforms
is virtually nil
um my hypothesis is that if you're using
power bi or Tableau you can Source data
probably from relational database or
like a CSV file and I would probably
have a workflow where I'm routinely
populating data that I could then
visualize I may be off base there uh but
if if someone said hey you've got to use
power bi tomorrow that's an approach
that I would assume that I could take
can't go without saying to check out the
connect deposit connect docs that Connor
shared there too
um and how very looks like you have a
meeting with the team tomorrow so
perfect timing to chat about that too
cool
okay another anonymous question on slido
was do you see our markdown or cordos
publishing functionality used in actuary
stats work for example publishing your
notebooks into tables docs or slides
directly
not as often as I would like uh I am a
big big fan of our markdown slash Porto
um I'm a little bit late to the party on
cuarto I I use it
um the differences between partner or
markdown I'm still learning so I kind of
use the terms interchangeably uh I I
wrote a 600 page textbook using our
markdown uh I do pretty much all of my
work in or markdown I I find that I'm
I'm writing notes and
long-form comments suddenly become the
most important bit in the document and
so which is
becomes easy to have our markdowns you
know as my starting point for work
professionally I've used it a lot
um the stakeholders very often will want
uh this isn't all that they want but
very often they can be satisfied with a
reasonably concise and informative Word
document or PDF if you'd rather but
giving them a Word document like okay
here you go here are the tables and here
are the graphs and here's the executive
summary uh I I think that's a great way
to share information
actuaries are not using it as much I
think there's there's not as much
awareness of uh or markdown I think the
initial presumption is that R's greatest
strength or only strength rather is in
calculation it can absolutely do that
it's got an incredible library of
statistical and machine learning
functionality but it does a lot more
than that that is slowly changing as
with adoption of our generally
I see that as being a real big selling
point when people find out that they can
replace a very typical Actuarial uh and
kind of analytic workflow where I create
a plot in Excel and I have to copy and
paste it into word that's operationally
inefficient it's operationally dangerous
so the the notion that my entire
analytics report is in one file
uh all of the code all of the narrative
all of the tables uh it's like telling
me that I can breathe underwater and fly
it's really fantastic so I think that as
actually become aware of that capability
they will get pretty happy about it and
as will the people who need to
communicate with actuars
I like the way you put that copying and
pasting is operationally dangerous yeah
yeah I I I'm not the only actor who has
been burned by that where you're in a
meeting and everyone is looking at the
same file and the plot didn't update
what do you mean we're losing one
billion dollars a day oh sorry that's
yesterday's graph we're actually
it's really cool that your book was was
built on our markdown as well
um I was I was wondering like what was
that process like of writing a book and
and how did you decide that you were
ready to to write a book
um two things one I'll start off by
saying that if it were not for more
markdown there's no way I ever would
have written that thing uh I I can't
imagine certainly I'm not going to write
the entire document in law Tech uh there
are people who can and God bless them
I'm not the sort of person that could
have
that much law Tech to uh to think about
um nor do I want to juggle about
12 or 13 different uh Word documents or
one monolithic Word document so our
markdown was a tremendous solution and
it was really empowering
the idea for the book came about from
workshops that I and others have been
doing for for the cas
um we had kind of like one day workshops
day and a half workshops
and I found that there was a lot of
foundational material I'm thinking about
like vectors and slicing vectors and
concatenation uh and lists and data
frames this was taking up a large amount
of kind of scarce time you know teach
somebody to be an actuary using R in
about seven and a half hours that's a
tall order and when you spend about
three hours or more just making sure
that folks understand what a data frame
is that scares time that we're losing
so those early slide decks uh probably
all of which were written in markdown by
the way and translating to reveal JS or
something like that we already had all
of the script for for those and I I
sat down with those decks and said okay
these look like book chapters so you
take a look at 45 minute sessions and
you've already got a lot of the code in
the examples and then at the time I
thought I'll just splash this out with a
few paragraphs and bang I'll have a book
wound up being more complicated than
that
it turns out that it it it does take a
little bit of time to write all of the
words in such a way that they make sense
uh but at that point it was too late I
was already I think 80 pages into it and
uh I just needed to finish so that's
that's kind of a story about how that
got started we started with with some
more down uh files
the the use that the need for it is to
give folks some foundational knowledge
and uh just kind of grew from there
awesome thank you
um one other anonymous question that
came in and thank you to the team
Gathering those for me in the background
with how do you share your work
currently especially when teams don't
have R and need to upload CSV files
um I don't have a real strong need to do
that so my sharing use case is probably
not going to resemble yours because I'm
guessing the question comes from some
points of friction
uh what I've done
is I'm going to say share points
um grad school projects I'm near the end
of a master's degree and so I have had
some grad school projects it's it's
Google Drive uh you know the kids they
love Google whereas the you know the
older corporate people uh like
SharePoint uh they're both fine uh that
that's what I use to share to share data
like CSV files what I love to do is to
collaborate on GitHub because it is
controlled
um it feels safe and deliberate
uh there are obviously some
frictional points there as well but
those beyond that I'm curious what other
folks use uh if there is some
interesting Magic Bullet out there
yeah any any thoughts feel free to just
unmute I can watch or raise your hand
here
I know one way that came up previously
in a hangout was creating a shiny
application where
people who didn't use R could upload the
data set and and work with it in the app
but yeah any other ideas feel free to
share in the chat too
um another question I I actually meant
to ask you this in the beginning but
thinking about the projects that you've
been working on lately and and thinking
into maybe the next year ahead for your
team what's something that you're really
excited about
me
yeah
oh my
God I'm caught off guard by that
um my immediate response is kind of
disheartening what I'm not I don't know
that I'm excited about anything I'll say
this
um I I'm excited about my next trip to a
new country to to talk about over
um I'm cheating a little bit here I I
went to South America for the first time
uh last year I was invited to give a one
day workshop on um uh statistical
learning in Bogota Colombia that was
fantastic yeah similar to the experience
that I had going to Germany and seeing a
fresh perspective on the work that I was
doing
ditto down there uh the the folks there
were just super motivated and they had a
just a really interesting way of looking
at things and I enjoyed uh having the
opportunity to interact with other folks
uh it's been a little while now but I
taught I co-instructed a short course on
R in uh in Rwanda uh that was fun so
nothing nothing like that on the radar
so I can't really claim to be excited
about that but um if anybody is outside
of the United States particularly South
America or Africa uh and you want me to
like I'll pay my own airfare but if
you'll uh give me an audience for like a
couple of days or a week I'd love to go
teach art to anybody that wants to be
taught by me
what's the best place for people to
follow up with you on that is it
LinkedIn
uh that's a good place yeah uh and feel
free to email me directly I'm going to
give you my workplace email in the chat
so there's my professional place and
then you can also find me uh to I have
because I've got an R crowd here uh I've
got my um
kind of Consulting slash personal email
address in there as well
uh that's a really really awful R joke
that I made when I created a Blog over
10 years ago that I'm gonna just kind of
sticking with for now
awesome thank you okay another anonymous
question I saw that came in is is there
much of an Actuarial R Community for
example folks collaborating on common
packages with developers between firms
or sharing use cases and best practices
so um I think there is not yet a
community
that we're actively working to create
one uh there is a click
there there is a small group of people
um every two weeks there there's a um a
meet-up of some folks a virtual Meetup
of uh actuaries who are using open
source generally we've got we've got
some python books on there as well uh so
so there's a click but not yet a
community
how would we find out about this click
if we were interested
uh good question I hate to sound kind of
kind of gatekeepy but um I think it
might have to be an actuary
um oh yes I mean if there if somebody is
an actuary that wants to send me the
deal okay
um and send me an email and have a bit
of patience I get a lot of email and my
response rate is not what I would like
it to be
um trust me I really want to respond but
I get a lot of email but please please
please reach out to me or uh send me and
find me on LinkedIn as well
um having a a space for actuaries and
non-actuaries to uh to connect with
that's actually a really good thing uh
that that's a good idea
um and I'd love to work with any
non-actuaries to make that happen
because you know if anybody wants to hit
me up about that I'm glancing at the
atom and uh my uh gallery
sounds like Javier has a yeah
who's gonna say it sounds like Javier
has a lot of experience working with
actuaries as well
yeah great great yeah good to uh good to
meet you both
okay Bill had a question in the chat and
I'm going to read a bill because I don't
think you are a muting here but
um the question is let me summarize a
little bit do you have any opinion on
using chat GPT and the effects on your
industry
um not yet
the only thing that I know I know very
little about chat gbt uh I want to be
more conversant in AI a few years back I
just kind of dabbled uh uh with it just
some very very basic exercises just to
understand kind of the mechanical flow
um I'm blanking on the co-author but the
JJ Lair has a really good book uh about
uh about AI that was kind of my intro to
that
um
AI generally it is a
how do I phrase this it's a slightly
awkward fit for Actuarial practice and
and that's my view and it may be wrong
they're definitely cases where it works
my sense is that AI relies on a lot of
observations
insurance claims thankfully are pretty
rare so those observations are kind of
hard to come by now that's not to say
that it has no place whatsoever in the
actual real workflow and we've got some
papers that have looked at this um
last year at a conference we had a
really good talk about the long
short-term memory of models in uh in
loss reserving so that's an active
conversation and we're looking at more
and more applications uh Ron Richmond
will throw his name out there is uh a
very very talented act where he was
looking at Ai and deep learning in
Actuarial applications returning to chat
GPT
I've already outed myself as an old man
and I haven't really used it very much
but other than I think it was last week
or the week before I posted something on
LinkedIn someone had had posed a
question to chat GPT about the Grateful
Dead uh I'm a big deadhead and and the
answer was just wrong
well
um so
I know that some actuaries have fed an
Actuarial exam to see if it can pass and
so forth can't so that's good news for
the profession uh I suppose uh but uh
hey Brian that's called hallucinating as
a deadhead you should be familiar with
that concept
um
database nerd and don't get me started
on uh on the statistical analysis of
Grateful Dead performances but um at the
moment especially specifically something
like gbt
um they're not active applications that
I'm aware of deep learning generally
yeah uh there are a few but um
I see a lot more scope for Lyft for
actuaries out of Bayesian techniques
because
we simply don't have a lot of
observations but we have loads of
kind of qualitative uh wisdom to bring
to bear and I would say that Bayesian
techniques are just woefully
underutilized the
actuaries were at the Forefront of
promoting Beijing taking for a long time
there's a really good book called the
theory that wouldn't die uh some of it's
like lady tasting tea it's it's kind of
a popular easy ish to read book about
statistics there is an entire chapter
about actuaries one of the few books
you're going to find that will do that
uh
but they're just not mainstream and
especially with the advances in
something like mcmc there's no reason
why we can't be using them so I'm loads
more bullish on Bayesian techniques than
I am on deep learning not immune to uh
to deep learning that is something that
we're looking at but I see a lot more
lift out of Bayesian techniques
just to confirm the book that you
mentioned by JJ Lair is that the Deep
learning with our book
probably he had a co-author on that yep
with Francois and Tomas let me put that
into the chat again here because I I
actually just learned this week that
they updated this book so there's a
second edition oh great they had some
new ones in the office then I asked JJ
to sign one the other day for the
AstraZeneca conference okay you know
that that's a really fantastic book uh
I'll need to pick up the second edition
yeah
awesome let me just double check here
whether oh I see a few new questions
here
um I was gonna say if there's questions
I have missed in the last remaining five
minutes or so here feel free to just
raise your hand
on Zoom um but Santiago I see one in the
the chat here
uh it wasn't like an actual question but
um on the conversation of gen Ai and
foundational models I'm sure many others
have gotten this question we've been
asked to look for applications of these
things and how can we start applying
them internally
um I don't think they realize
applications are fewer and far between
uh but it depends I don't know one of my
proposals was
uh as a consulting firm they're very big
on brand I'm sure others have to deal
with that too like what to capitalize
when not to capitalize
why not train
uh something like falcon or Chachi PT on
your brand guide
so that you don't have to read it you
just pass it your documents and it would
Auto brand fix things for you
that was kind of like a I don't know a
sarcastic response but I feel like there
would be application for that
sarcastic or not so it sounds like
um
a decent place for it I
I think there was a lot of automatable
uh activity that that chat GPT can can
help with
I love that example Santiago I would
I know we've talked about this before
here but I always think the best way to
make your like proof of concept or
something that you share with your your
leadership team Stand Out is to actually
use your company brand in I don't know
if it was a shiny app like using your
logo and the the company colors
which I know Javier had wrote in a blog
post before would be cool to see if you
could run that through
shot GPT
let's see any other questions that I may
have missed here
a question
um
I love to ask Brian is
thinking about your career so far and
your mentors along the way throughout
your career is there a piece of career
advice that stands out to you
um good question uh
I'm not sure that I'm an amazing person
to give career advice I've had a lot of
luck over the years but um
I I I've kind of uh randomly gone from
one thing to the next and I don't know
that that's great advice
um or maybe I could spin that positively
and just just say
um
I feel like I benefited from an openness
to uh to do other things and also just
in Awareness that depending on what
industry you're in you will need some
resilience I worked for a really cool
really fun startup for about a year
until it it just evaporated like you're
going to work one day and they say well
you know it's been fun but the market
has other ideas about the viability of
what we're all doing here so you do need
some resiliency and some openness
um and I guess you know the mentor there
has just been experienced just just
having lived through uh some some good
fortune and and some not so good uh
episodes uh it has been uh uh what has
taught me that
um I I will say though that I've got a
really really cool Network I've worked
with some really really great people
um this is advice I I'm not going to be
the first person to have shared this but
um as often as you can try to make sure
that you're the dumbest person at the
table
um you know not so hard for me but um
being deliberate about that yeah has
been uh has been useful
I I appreciate that advice and I
I also think just like
listening to you today
um what I've learned is to also ask for
things that you want like if you want to
go and travel to a different country and
teach a workshop there ask people
if if they're looking for that
um Brian thank you so much for joining
us today and and sharing your experience
this has been great I'm going to share
your LinkedIn here in the chat for
everybody as well
but thank you all for the great
questions too
have a great rest of the day everybody